[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
I've noticed that a lot of comedians are
good actors dramatic actors yeah
dramatic definitely yeah because there
is a a real dark and sadness to them and
then oh yeah they can tap into it you
don't think you get funny from having a
great life well I had a great life did
you yeah and that's the sadness of it
I wanted some challenge in life yeah and
yet I was handed everything yeah bummer
we are really tall and that's not fair I
am tall I'll tell people that people
will see him on stage and they'll think
I didn't know he's that tall yeah I
don't say well I didn't know you existed
yeah so too shiny
how do you like that Lisa took care of
you yeah not just me now think about it
now you two girls right you know what
you guys remind me of right now right
Filipina versions of the [ __ ] two
girls in The Shining oh yeah all right
and that's what I think right now let's
yeah you kind of look like them too yeah
yeah you ever seen The Shining no look
at him right there that's them that's
you two this is YouTube right now that's
what you should have been Halloween this
is what you two are right now right dude
and I don't [ __ ] if you scared the [ __ ]
out of me
instead of like that hotel where would
it be though
well then okay
[Laughter]
the audience knows yeah yeah that is you
guys that's you guys right there because
you guys sound similar you talk in the
same you talk you have the same
intonation when you talk yeah and I
that's just like these little creepy
girls like I bet you if I can say at the
same time to say a number one through
ten you'll say the same number no okay
on the count of three say the number one
through whichever number you're thinking
one through ten one two three four okay
never mind
did not work that was crazy we can do it
again ready yeah okay
wait we should look at each other no no
it's got to be just telepathic you just
have to know yeah yeah you have to know
that you're thinking you're both
thinking of the same number the exact
same time you're both sisters your blood
there's a connection Bobby and I have
the same connection yeah we're about One
Second Glance yeah Andrew we do we we
have the same connection yeah uh ready
yeah one two three nine whoa whoa let's
do you and I one two two three three
oh oh
my God you guys do it one two three
all right we can do it ready we can do
it one two three two
oh [ __ ]
that's why this show is good that's why
we're connected
and we should take that to Vegas dude
that was good I can't [ __ ] believe it
we might reconnect that was really good
you want to try again okay ready one two
three
[Laughter]
[Applause]
we are very good today I was in a coffee
shop and I saw they had they added
unfortunately the like that new [ __ ]
like sign of like science is Real Love
Is Love we in this house around here no
this is this is in Philadelphia I'd go
put a brick
dude and I was sitting there just kind
of like dude it's literally you know
like you see a crucifix now and you're
just like yeah the crucifix that's like
new crucifix now like people have it's
like charged and it's like yeah this is
our thing and I was I was getting
someone said whoa I'm gonna ask him like
can you take that down please it's
making me uncomfortable that's [ __ ]
yeah so because dude the thing they
don't put on there is like and also if
you disagree you're a [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] you I hope you [ __ ] die
it's really implied when you say science
is real yeah dude it's like yeah
dude I was wincing I was in line just
going uh lady's like can I help you and
I was like
[Music]
how often I wonder how often she sees
that face throughout the day looking at
that sign yeah just like it is funny
because the science is real is in the
room then behind the register is a girl
who's in her 20s that has crystals
that's a good point are there any milk
crates at your parents house at the
moment oh I I know but you don't know
about the bags
a bag of milk delicious it smell yeah
I'm not we used to be a big meal family
put the bag in the refrigerator they
give you like that I don't know how to
do it up there and and how do you put a
bag what do you know about bag milk look
at them what do you mean he has a bag of
milk
I resent that I'm ambiguous to that
comment
amphibious to your insult
[Laughter]
there is basically a 99
probability that you're holding
something that the Fjord drank from
at his vacation home
this is Hitler's cup that was Hitler's
cup yeah
put it to your lips put it to your lips
Isn't that cool
happy birthday
oh this is the best birthday
I'm supposed to destroy it
was supposed to destroy it no you can
get a lot of money for that you can get
along
Amelia
excited
[Applause]
yes
it totally belonged to Hitler
[Music]
I did oh my god do you realized he may
have been just been like go get those
gypsies let's sit from it oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] is
dude foreign
[Laughter]
oh this is great
put your coffee in it I'm
just gonna keep it right here and put
the top back on it
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
oh I love this new angle of birthday
gifts fun right to give people stuff
that they can't keep
this is a new look huh yeah you decided
to keep your [ __ ] gigantic helmet on
to the whole thing yeah it's uh kind of
makes my head even bigger than it
already is yeah kinda definitely does
I love this I didn't know the air was a
[ __ ] South Korean Power Ranger this
is very exciting
is that GoPro on no I think I forgot to
turn it on
real that would have been a great idea
yeah real missed opportunity there Hans
wow
oops Hans Kim I feel like you right now
look like the Mortal Kombat character
whose finishing move only works on women
I never I can never finish with women
but I'm gonna get Hans Camp Hans Kim's
in the [ __ ] Zone how do you feel Hans
how's this week been for you it's been
amazing Tony I went to New York City
with you I felt like the prince of New
York with my with my daddy Tony
[Laughter]
you did good we had good work four crazy
ass sold out shows easy breezy ate a lot
rested a lot yeah ate a lot of Italian
food with you we did we did we did the
[ __ ] tourist trap we were like little
boy blue in his [ __ ] Gary Clark hat
over here we did the tourists oh this
guy's poor guy I'm watching his soul
leave his body it's incredible oh he's
[ __ ] red and bullied right now I love
it man that guy's headwear is ridiculous
foreign yeah
I've been through this before I've been
too mean to people on this stage before
I feel like this guy's gonna put out a
video that's just tightly edited of mean
stuff and say this is what this guy said
to me during South Carolina Heritage
Month
my sweet sweet Hans Kim uh yeah we had a
lot of fun in New York at one point I'll
tell you guys this a little inside
information Hans Kim closed the door in
the green room and went pee and it was
so [ __ ] loud it was incredible I
don't think I've ever heard a peace
stream quite as powerful as yours are
you aware that you have a strong pastry
me and William were laughing very hard
on the other side of the door I heard
this mentioned before to me now do you
think it's because you have a big penis
or a big pee hole
because it sounded like you're hung
which is also your middle name so that's
pretty cool
Kim
by the way I I want to just make an
announcement to the hey babe fans I will
not eat a ounce of turkey on Thursday so
don't tag me in pictures of it if you
see me going straight to Staten Island
don't even [ __ ] mention because vegan
there's turkeys no there's turkey
turkeys wild turkeys live in my
neighborhood no Chris you'd be driving
down like the Boulevard in Staten Island
there's like legitimate wild turkeys
everywhere and when you live around
turkeys first of all what turkeys do is
the reason why they they congregate
around Deer they eat the deer [ __ ] and
when you see them they are disgusting
turkeys turkeys are disgusting eating
[ __ ] they'll like literally walk up to
my door and they go like and if you go
out the window if you go they'll go back
kind of like the guys at the bars in
Staten Island
[Laughter]
it does sound like a Staten Island guys
would call gays couple of wild turkeys
once I was in Pittsburgh and um we all
went out and then we came back to the
hotel and somebody had robbed the hotel
which is really robbed the hotel and
we're like What did they take like the
little soaps and stuff like that like
did they take all that little stuff but
they like basically came in and it's
like can I help you and they robbed the
hotel I was like how cool is that you
know like wow just to like the guy
behind the counter like you know because
we all know late night at the hotel they
have that Indian dude sleeping in the
back security thing where you have to
like buzz in I was that was before that
it's the Indian Family behind the desk
guy comes out at three in the morning in
his pajamas hey what's up he's cooking
something in the back you can smell the
ramen or whatever
[Laughter]
I like a nice Residence Inn I like a
place do you like it I like where you
can do your laundry middle of the road
is the best because the four seas is too
much because the Wi-Fi is 18 the
breakfast is 90. yeah I want to hate can
I say this yeah
I can't stand
you talking about women
right and that's your sketch or whatever
they're stupid the most overrated Hotel
chain I agree I agree Keith Robinson is
his favorite Hotel chain and I tell him
he's Tracy you are the most black white
trash human being I've ever met my wife
you have to say it after right after a
second stroke I didn't think hey
Different Strokes
are the same folks but he loves a w and
I feel like slapping you Joe because I
know he can't
I don't know with one side he can't
you're saying he's you're saying he's
half he's white trash and black
which side do you think is white trash
probably the side that's still working
yeah
come on Dave I'm nice
for some reason we used to get a ton of
like free Monster energy drinks to the
house and Adam would drink them like
every morning like every afternoon and
then that was the when we like
discovered what um what is it when you
get the rocks in your dick oh uh uh uh
kidney stones yeah Stones yeah you got
Stones yeah no yeah I had to look in his
pee hole like no I did not look like
dude he's like it's in there I swear
keep looking I don't see it it if you
kiss it sometimes the stones will come
out oh all right I'll just suck on it
until the stones come out man yeah just
suck just suck on it to all the kidney
stones come out it hurts
no dude I never yeah that's right one
time now did Adam have him did he have
them um you know they break them up
right like they do this thing where they
can break them up they like have to like
yeah they massage your car kind of like
one of those glow sticks where you crack
them yeah you have to crack the [ __ ] in
half and smack it you have to smack it a
few things pepper grate it
say when
the Northeast is just better the
Northeast I love it that's just a
section of the world come on I thought
the Northeast might be the best section
of the world get all the seasons every
season the food's awesome good accents
good sports teams culture history get a
sense of humor too good sense of humor
the Atlantic Ocean the Atlantic Ocean
Atlantic Ocean dude
put my toes in the water yeah I think
the Northeast United States and the
Northeast part of Canada dude [ __ ]
Nova Scotia gorgeous Halifax Nova Scotia
Prince Edward I look at the muscles
I mean seriously what part what's the
better part of the world I love I do
love I mean we've really gotten over the
past whatever like year we've really
traveled and got to see a lot of cities
a lot of places like Cincinnati and yeah
they're like we really got out there
Cleveland no did you know there's
another part of the U.S on the west they
use different money out there how do you
feel about anal
that I've never felt like your arm was
longer
that thing comes
experienced anything like that yeah he's
Voldemort he's like [ __ ] Uncle Sam
how do you feel about it like a [ __ ]
Ripley's Believe It or Not illusion
you're like what Christ you brought it
up like how do you feel about it uh as a
as receiving obviously yeah yeah
um I didn't do a joke in the ACT about
having a finger in my mind finally yeah
I've had a couple fingers in my body
I've never no I don't think so yeah you
know I don't ask too many questions yeah
um I just let them whatever they're
gonna do uh I've never it's whenever it
happens I'm like
I'm not like blown away by this like I'm
not gonna build my life around this Neil
can I ask you a question go ahead
um you don't strike me as someone who's
Blown Away by anything so this that I no
offense taken okay so how do you know
if you like it you're asking me
I if your joy level is like four I went
to a
urologist yeah 18 years ago that's how
long I've had erect I was [ __ ] I'm
kidding no I told you the joke that
entrepelsh we me I had an erectile
dysfunction and I was like dude I can't
because it was so stressful no man we
gotta it's because we're using laptops
like no dummy we're both [ __ ]
stressed to our ad you're like a week
from Africa
you know it's a good lesson because
everyone now just thinks they're right
all the time yeah and they don't want to
be wrong it's like go do something and
then come back to it maybe you're not
you're the greatest city in the world
like wherever you live like ah no way I
don't need to yeah how would you say
it's a great right because pizza's not
even New York it's in New Jersey yeah or
Connecticut or Connecticut yeah Chinese
is in Jersey it's like you're crazy
you're not right right you have no
knowledge of the world in order to make
that idea it's something that it's like
this imperiousness everyone has like
they issue these edicts as if it's like
law as if it's final as if nobody's
human it makes mistakes or grows or
learns new things like you learned
something new that word imperious you
use it twice today I think that's the
seventh oh really I think I used it four
times in the car
I noticed I was like oh that's a big
word and now it's like ah enough it's
been knocking at me you definitely just
learned a word I looked that up this
morning I was like that would be good to
stay at the podcast
that sounds smart does anyone refuse to
take those shoes off
no one will come in
you just won't let him in for for not
taking the shoes off second if you're
that
ambivalent am I using that word right
maybe if you're that like
disrespectful to in somebody's home but
what makes them feel safe and
comfortable where you're like [ __ ] this
it's like I don't want you [ __ ] here
I know but what if they just did it well
like imagine Larry David and you're like
uh you didn't tell you didn't tell me
the groceries if I just did it I would
have told you and I also have I also
have clean Socks by the door in case
people don't have socks that's nice but
um what I feel like imagine Larry David
yeah you didn't tell myself so you're
saying this example is Imagine The King
The King not someone I like but the
number one king of Jews right
and he comes in you're like oh hey man
would you mind taking shoes off but do
it I'll be Larry David uh okay hey uh
will you please take your shoes off
funny I love that energy but I really
have a thing I have OCD and it's I need
you to that's not really my thing take
your shoes off I I have the um foot
covers that's the best thing I could do
I don't know he wouldn't do that there's
no way you would do that I felt I felt
him I felt him paddling through me let's
get him on the phone totally see him get
him on the phone I'll get Larry David on
the phone do you know him you're
Hollywood I do and I've never called him
and if you texted twice
well I texted him twice he texted me
back you're gonna call in a favor of
Larry David
just to find out how he'd feel about
these shoes I don't feel like it's a
favor as much as I feel like it's a game
that that is a game both that he would
like to play but also like you're saying
this is his point of view I'm saying
strongly I think he's more empathetic
than this
Nah if he's not into taking I could see
him going like I don't sing happy
birthday he refuses to sing Happy
Birthday as everybody's yelling that's
that's Curb Your Enthusiasm Larry that's
him that's what he wants to be that's
who he is
really not getting service right now oh
wait
what are the chances of him answering
I'm actually so nervous right now
because even if he doesn't answer he saw
a missed call also does he have your
number saved he's texted me once he's
texting me back once he liked my show as
we see it and he talked to me and
forwarded to an automatic voice wow
forwarded
that doesn't mean hello there's a
voicemail
forwarded that means he's doing
something too important like leaving his
shoes on
he's busy leaving his shoes on dude I
want to slide really wanted I really
want I almost want to ask you know what
I might do and if so we'll cut to it
here I might ask
telling the situation and ask him what
he would do and maybe he could send a
video and I'll just cut to it so we'll
cut to it and we'll come back and we'll
do a response Larry David is going to
send you a [ __ ] video of how he'd
handle your your request with his lunacy
I can't tell by your tone are you
yelling at me I read my voice do you
think it's a disbelieving raising do you
think he's more or more willing to take
his shoes off for me or send me the
video
that's a good question thank you I
really want him to I I did say could you
call me for something it's time
sensitive and now I'm like really
literally phoning it in with this man
you're phoning it in yeah like that's
not when to use it I didn't think it was
a favor until that I mean imagine you're
in a p you're like in a pitch and you're
like what if we get Larry David
reception like I think I've
[ __ ] I don't think I can call him I just
called him about something else and I
should not have used what'd you call him
for
I had a guy at my house and he thought
that Larry wouldn't take his shoes off
well that's ridiculous of course he
would take his shoes off but that's what
I said
so I had to proof it to this guy okay
that makes total sense well buy your
show yeah is that how you celebrate it
yeah he knows the task right now he's
pretending to be Chappelle talking to
Fox News about being a state of Comedy
yes
fighting PC culture if the closest thing
you have to a brother Louis J Gomez
happens to come up real free feel free
to roll with that
just throwing it back to Lewis over and
over so funny all right all right all
right I'm muting and now adding call
so loud
oh hey Dave how are you
hello
hello
I'm good I'm on a train so apologies can
you hear me oh it's quite all right I'm
outside I just wanted to call you real
quick because I know I only have about
four minutes that's okay I could have
like one percent batteries
oh what is that I wanted to get in quick
and talk to you about Louis J Gomez
easily one of the funniest people I've
ever in my life yes
I mean that man is very important to me
he is like a brother
yes
we have established a connection that is
a bond that is unbreakable yes I would
honestly say that I'd take a bullet for
Lewis Jacob you know he was incredible I
mean I met him at gas digital and he was
so influential yes visual is crazy how
hard I've seen work on it and how
foreign
[Music]
has done more for comedy than anybody in
the world and his son his son James if
he doesn't eat loose we'll rip someone's
head off
oh I love that I mean he was incredibly
kind too which was another video
because he's a true Peach yeah he was
very generous I mean he led us into his
entire Studio he has to pretend this is
all normal
he was just incredibly incredibly
generous what's incredible is that he
actually campaigned for Joe Biden we can
find very a lot of people don't know
that a lot of people don't know yeah
Lewis is very liberal
you know what I like about that though
because first of all it's good to get
people that aren't just super
conservative especially working for
someone like Tucker because then it gets
the message out even stronger Tucker has
my number told me that he doesn't even
believe in science when it comes to
things
different bags of body parts oh God
that's funny they see insane I'm telling
you right now it's almost like he's sick
in the head but he's a good man again
lose the peach yeah no no I loved him
and he um you know obviously said the
same about you and I mentioned and I
know Dave I mean obviously thinking
about him anymore
by the way was I mean the fact that
obviously you're genius at your comedy
but perspect that you have the courage I
don't even honestly honestly I just
you know and what's great about Lewis is
he can get so fast
he's in really good shape
yeah he fluctuates that's why I'm
worried about Lewis I'm worried about
his fluctuation in weight oh man I'll
tell you from experience from a week and
a half ago he was looking very good
foreign
[Applause]
episode on exploring comedy right now
because obviously with both culture and
cancel culture there's so much resources
[Music]
please he loves War culture
the interesting thing when I interviewed
him his insight into what was happening
like changed our entire premise of the
documentary it was about like the
sanctuaries are existing for comics and
still do like real unfiltered because
live copies always been you know the
dangerous edgy comment if you don't know
what's going to happen when you're on
the team right exactly you don't know
what but you know what you're going to
get with Louis J Gomez
fluctuates Dangerously in life
[Laughter]
figured it out yet
I just wish you would stop having such
an aggressive foot fetish
very dangerous
now I'm wondering I'm like are my feet
not good enough
she wanted to [ __ ] dude
he'll probably come his pants
had to go you've been very nice I'm
sorry I gotta run but I was not talking
to you and uh hopefully I'll reach out
yeah are you gonna think about it at all
it would be like a fast think about it
and I'll let you know I'm gonna think
about Lewis a little bit more too
and then we'll talk through absolutely
goodbye thank you so much
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]